so this talks about JavaScript and I
want to talk about JavaScript eventually
but first I would like to talk about
English and not English as we know it
but old English it would be
unrecognizable to you or me in written
form or in spoken form but it came from
the same language family as Dutch and
German and Icelandic and if things had
gone differently modern English would
would resemble those languages much more
closely but in the 11th century William
the second decided he wanted to be king
of England so he gathered an army in
Normandy and he evaded he invaded the
country across the channel and he won
and many of those who had fought in his
army were rewarded with land and power
and they became the new ruling class in
England and they brought with them a
dialect of old French that had a lasting
influence on English vocabulary as Old
English evolved into Middle English
large numbers of French loanwords found
their way into the language and over the
next few centuries as Middle English
became modern English the language
borrowed more and more words mainly from
classical sources the translation of
theological texts from Latin reveals
gaps in English vocabulary and the
simplest solution was to adopt the Latin
word into English but there were people
who decried what they saw as a
bastardization of the English tongue and
it they call these new words in corn
terms and in corn being a kind of
inkwell and so you know a marker of a
snobbish writer and instead of using
these borrowed words they would try to
resurrect archaic words from English
that had fallen out of favor or they
would try to invent new words from
dramatic roots but these words usually
didn't catch on a classical scholar
named John cheek was one of the most
vocal critics of in corn terms and
because he's speaking in metaphor here
it's not entirely clear to me what he
thinks will actually happen if the worst
case comes to pass but nearly 500 years
later we can see that English has not
declared bankruptcy by any means and the
way I know this is that cheek is running
in early modern English yet we can all
read
understand his words with very little
difficulty say for the creative spelling
but even at the time the purists were in
the minority George petty sums up the
rebuttal here he says that the purists
apply the label in corn term
inconsistently and only for the words
that they don't like he says that half
the words in English are borrowed from
somewhere and only the new borrowings
get scrutinized because their novelty
makes them seem strange he says that
borrowing is healthy for a language but
more than that it's unavoidable it's
something that all languages do I know
not how we should speak anything without
blacking our mouths with ink so
linguistic purism lost the battle for
English and we now know that their
worries were largely overblown but for
funs sake there are some small corners
of the english-speaking world who
practice what's called anglish which is
English with as few borrowed words as
possible remaining true to its
anglo-saxon roots it's like an
alternative history sort of linguistics
what if the Normans hadn't conquered
England what might our language sound
like there's a wiki for english of
course and it's called the english much
a mutt being an old word for a
discussion and the word they've decided
to use to replace wiki being of hawaiian
origin and so we can go there to learn
some things about our own country in
english the united states of america
would be the Bandit folk domes of a
Marik's land and you could learn that
the BFA emerged from 13 British
Cycling's who drafted at acknowledged
hood of self dhum in 1776 you learn that
the leader of America's land is for
stood a Barack Obama of the folk Reich
mutt band which is way cooler sending
than democratic party for citizens like
he should be like like on a horse or
something but like do you see how
ridiculous this gets and how quickly
many years ago we have lexical purists
in English and they lost they lost in
part because they were warning of a
vague nonspecific doom that would come
from
from these evil new words but the only
thing that offended them about the words
was the alien origin they weren't
arguing that the words were unclear or
that they couldn't be used well they
didn't like the new words because they
were new so now I'd like to talk about
French French is different obviously it
dates back to Julius Caesar's conquest
of Gaul and the first century BC so it's
derived mainly from Latin but along the
way French took a different path in 1634
Cardinal Richelieu created a body calm
academie francaise dedicated to the the
purification and preservation of French
whereas England had largely ignored John
cheek and the other doomsayers there was
one hugely influential Frenchman who
declared that it was worth it to protect
his language from the influence of other
languages the Academy still exists today
the French government declares the
official authority on the French
language there's no equivalent body for
English there are people who release
dictionaries and people who read grammar
books but no one who claims to be an
authority for all the English spoken and
written throughout the world there are
40 seats in the Academy and members hold
their seat until they die or step down
at which time the other members vote on
a replacement they have uniforms you are
looking at the ceremonial uniform of the
members of the Academy you can see they
take this very seriously and they
publish the official dictionary of the
French language and they have another
function that opens them up to ridicule
they try to prevent the adoption of
loanwords English language culture is
worldwide and our words worm their way
into other languages just as Latin words
once worms their way into ours and the
Academy tries to keep french harmonious
by providing French derived equivalents
to English loanwords this isn't much
different from the efforts of English as
linguistic purists except that in French
these efforts are blessed by the
government but the Academy lacks any
sort of enforcement mechanism even
within the government so in practice
many of these recommendations are
ignored by French speakers in January
friends Frances general Commission of
terminology and neologisms and
that use of the word hashtag is
discouraged among francophones and the
preferred term is mo diez which
literally means sharp word as in the
sharp symbol from musical notation I'm
going to try to make all of this
relevant to where we are today with our
with our own language I've not yet
decided which of these models is better
for describing how programming languages
evolve on one hand they have to be
understood by machines and the best way
to make sure all machines understand a
language the same way is to be very
specific about how the language is
designed so we need a top-down approach
we need a standards body on the other
hand standards bodies don't typically
try to specify style our coding styles
aren't shaped by the egg no script spec
their shapes by the code we've read out
there in the real world code patterns
are folk driven solutions to common
problems so we also need a robust
community in which people are writing
their own code and reading the code of
others after years of minimal change
javascript is evolving es5 intentionally
did not introduce new syntax so es6 is
the first time in over a decade that
javascript is poised to adopt new syntax
this is going to feel weird it must feel
weird because new syntax has to be
declared from on high some of the new
features are controversial and some of
them are not and as far as I can tell
nearly all the on controversial things
are the ones that add new features Maps
week max week Maps proxies and so on and
in browsers now we've got typed arrays
in support of WebGL and the other API is
the lettuce manipulate binary data and
the concept of a typed array is quite
foreign to how JavaScript usually works
but I've never seen art anyone argue
that typed arrays shouldn't be in Java
scripts because they were necessary to
do the things we want it to do whereas
to me most of the controversial
are the things that merely restate we
can already do some of the new syntax is
trying to replace patterns that
individual JavaScript errs have come up
with the existing patterns are bit
clumsy and they don't look quite as nice
but we invented them ourselves and so it
feels strange to have something come out
to replace all that work it feels like
l'académie française is telling us not
to use the words that we came up with
ourselves so the best example might be
the proposal for what's called maximally
minimal classes they're called maxim
only minimal because the prote the
proposed syntax is a very tiny evolution
over how people make classes in existing
JavaScript you can see the existing
syntax on the left and the proposed
syntax on the right they are
functionally equivalent no new features
are introduced there's no confusing new
semantics there's no gotchas this is
shortcut syntax it doesn't replace
prototypal inheritance it's just a
restatement of prototypical heritance
under under the hood it's nothing but
prototypes in theory this is about as
unthreatening as new syntax is going to
get it there are a couple new keywords
that are introduced but they're words
that were reserved by JavaScript years
ago and if we don't use them they're
just going to go to waste and the door
is open for the syntax to be extended in
the future right now there's no built-in
when you do class methods but a future
version of Eggman script could introduce
class methods through new syntax without
breaking backward compatibility but I
hear rebuttals there are there are a
number of reasons that you can be
against the the classes proposal but the
one that I read the most is the one that
makes the least sense to me class-based
inheritance is a javascript pattern that
has existed for years it's a subset of
prototypical inheritance and I know that
because we've been using prototypical
inheritance to emulate class-based
inheritance the strawman used
3gs is the example but you can look at a
backbone or jQuery UI or a half dozen
frameworks that everyone in this room
has used and we can talk about whether
it's a good pattern on the merits but it
drives me nuts when I see simplistic
opposition based on one person's
subjective idea of what javascript is
and isn't and even if you think ja that
classes aren't real JavaScript opposing
this syntax isn't going to make them go
away they already exist in half of your
favorite libraries the most common
rebuttal i see is from people who can't
disentangle the idea of classes from
java they see the word class and they
get shell shocked and flash back to some
horrible internship where they had to
spend all day in eclipse writing getter
and setter methods so yeah this is the
thing I was clearly working up to this
is but this isn't just about classes but
classes are the best example if you say
classes will turn javascript into Java
you're a modern-day jean chic you're
attacking the new words because they
come from a different language that you
don't like javascript is not java and it
won't turn into java just because we add
syntax for the classes that people are
already writing the status quo of
javascript the language that the purists
are trying to protect is a language that
has already borrowed half of its syntax
from java and a handful of jobs features
and that's how it'll continue to work
default parameters are coming they
already exist in a bunch of other
languages array comprehensions and
generators are coming over from python
es6 is not going is not inventing new
things out of thin air it's taking
things that have worked in other
languages and applying them to our own
we are going to black our mouths with
ink no matter what we do so here's the
problem introducing new syntax to
javascript is going to be hard for the
same reason that l'académie française
has trouble getting people to use their
words we're going to have new syntax for
classes and modules but in our world in
our world we already have several
different ways of doing classical
inheritance and several different ways
of modular writing code and it reminds
me of something else that's happening in
English when you want to refer to some
person who is hypothetical or whose
gender you don't know you've got a few
options older grammar books will tell
you that the third person singular
masculine can be used to refer to a
person of indeterminate gender but this
is this is falling out of favor it can
be semantically awkward and there are
people who think it perpetuates thinking
of men as the default and women is a
special case so some people have taken
it upon themselves to invent a new
gender-neutral pronoun for English a
mathematician named Michael Spivak
popularized the idea of taking the third
person plural them they and their and
dropping the th to turn each one into a
gender-neutral singular which is pretty
simple and arguably pretty elegant but
the practice is not caught on instead
what's caught on is too is either to say
he or she in each instance or more
commonly to use what's called the
singular vay to read to repurpose third
person plural as third person singular
it's not hard to argue that singular vay
is not the most well-designed solution
but that's the thing it didn't win
because it was elegant it won because
it's the solution that is most familiar
to English speakers and because it
doesn't require the teaching of an
entirely new word the singular of a
usage was able to spread organically
through popular use and to bring us back
to JavaScript I think we overlook that
that even though javascript is written
for machines to understand every line of
JavaScript that's written adds to a
giant corpus of code that other people
can read you probably learned English
from a grammar
look or a textbook but you became an
expert at English through reading books
and watching movies and talking to
people around you in English likewise
you may have learned how to code from a
book but you develop your coding skills
by reading the code of those around you
if I were trying to introduce a new word
into English I would try to convince a
high-profile source to start using it I
would get it into dictionaries I would
make it part of Associated Press style
I'd get a major news outlets used
regularly time at Time magazine spent
most of the 20th century trying to coin
new words of their own and stay they had
more misses than hits but they're
credited with inventing words like
socialite and intellivision list so it
helps to have major firepower behind new
words but it's no guarantee that they'll
catch on ideally people realize that the
new word represents something that
deserves to have a name and they start
to use it before they have time to come
up with something else but that's a lot
of maybes and if it doesn't quite work
out then you end up looking like an
idiot you know using this new word that
even been that no one understands what
it means so if the people in this room
wields any influence and I think they do
then we're going to be an important part
of what happens when es6 is final if you
don't like some of the new stuff that's
fine you can pretend it doesn't exist
you're not obligated to do anything but
if you like the new class syntax or the
new module syntax or destructuring or
block scope or whatever then you can do
some simple things to help them along
you can write documentation mdn is
probably going to have this covered but
it's not just the reference
documentation its blog posts it's stack
overflow tutorials code recipes anything
like that no matter how trivial e no
matter how trivial you think it is
because a lot of this will be brand new
to a lot of developers and they're going
to google it and there should be content
there
if you're in an environment that will
get new syntax quickly like node then
you don't have much of an excuse not to
to be the syntactic change that you want
to see if you write for the browser it's
not as easy but once es6 is finalized i
hope we can come together around a
canonical transpiler that will that will
let us all right es 6 or some reasonable
subset of es6 and get it transpired over
to es 3 for environments that need it
and hopefully this will be in a near
future when all browsers support source
maps so that we can do it as painlessly
as possible but here's the most
important part be a therapist people
fear change we hang around and we talk
about this stuff at conferences and on
mailing lists on Twitter and it's old
stuff to us but when it's unveiled to
the rest of the world there's going to
be a backlash too many people it's going
to seem jarring and strange here they
just learn JavaScript a couple years ago
and right as they thought they were
getting the hang of it there's this new
scary thing that reminds them of the
Java world they left behind I want you
to hug them tightly and whisper it's not
your fault over and over again tell them
it's going to be okay tell them they
don't have to be scared by new modest
and optional enhancements it's still
going to look and feel like JavaScript
and the next time that you worry about
where javascript is going remember that
500 years later we can still read the
words of John cheek the language you
love is not going anywhere and I think I
came in just under time so that's all
for me
you